i do have to mention this case though
this is from nbc it says a washington
state father killed his daughter's
19-year-old boyfriend for selling her
into a sex trafficking ring according to
police
the boyfriend's remains were discovered
in the trunk of an abandoned car on east
everett avenue in spokane last month
police said in a press conference
investigators believe the victim was
killed in november 2020. the girl's
father joe john eisenmann 60 was charged
with first-degree murders being held on
a million dollars bail um so police said
that eisenman learned in october 2020
that his juvenile daughter had been sex
trafficked in the seattle area and
obtained information that her boyfriend
was responsible according to the press
release eisenmann
was able to rescue his daughter and get
her back to her her home
that same month when the father learned
that his daughter's boyfriend was going
to be at a location in airway heights
eisenmann drove there and waited for the
19 year old to arrive
during that encounter eisenmann abducted
the victim tying him up and placing him
in the trunk of a vehicle eisenmann
subsequently assaulted the victim by
hitting him in the head with a
cinderblock and then stabbed him
repeatedly causing his death
um after the homicide eisenmann drove
the vehicle to a remote area and
abandoned the car with the body still
inside
unironically
this is uh father of the year i wish i
put me on that jury and i will sentence
him to a round of applause and free beer
for life
and um
i say that without any hint of irony
whatsoever assuming everything we just
heard is true i mean assuming these
details are all accurate
it's possible that they're not but on
the assumption that that this is all
true
um
i i would certainly hope that there's no
[Music]
jury in america even in washington state
that would convict this man and send him
to prison
i mean they might they might feel like
they have to convict him of something
you know slap on the wrist at worst
that naughty naughty don't do that next
time
send him on his way
but in reality this is this is
according to the details this is a good
father doing what a father should do
and doing what you know what most
fathers probably wouldn't do or a great
many fathers wouldn't but not because
they have a moral problem with it just
because they're worried you know they're
worried about their own livelihood and
they don't want to go to jail
but i can tell you one thing for sure
any father
if if their daughter is is
sex trafficked
any father would want to track down the
sex trafficker and kill him
and any any father would feel and would
be totally justified in doing so it's
just that if they wouldn't it's just
because they don't want to go to prison
which is you know which is not a
not an irrational
concern either
we think about what this guy did
according to the report this is from the
police
it's not even the defense attorney
making this claim this is the police
saying
that his daughter
was
made into a sex slave he goes and
rescues him her from sex slavery
gets her to safety
finds out who did it
tracks the guy down
beats him with a cinder block and stabs
him to death
this is they they literally made a movie
about that that's liam neeson and taken
and yeah that's just a movie but if
you've see it like nobody watches that
movie everyone you watch that movie
you're rooting for liam neeson
i feel the same way about it here um
that's
that is the correct fatherly response
to your daughter being sex trafficked
and the world is a better place today
without that scumbag with him stabbed to
death and stuffed in a trunk the world
is a much better place so
congratulations to that man
and uh
i hope he has a you know
i hope his father's day gift next year
is getting off on all charges because
that's what he deserves listen hit that
subscribe button right now do it right
now i thank you for your compliance it
is
somewhat appreciated